Với khu trở mốn mới gình đồng trên một em chế một ngày,
ám dụng với học sinh tiêu học,
là con em vùng đồng bảo sinh tập trở số,
mình đối và bại dưới sống hông,
học sinh thuộc hồ ngèo, khu cận ngèo,
học sinh quyết tật, học sinh mồ của y cả trá và mẹ,
biệt vòr dời, khu cỏng của lyd giống.
học sinh thuộc dịnh bảo trở xả hồi,
con người có công với cách mặt,
học sinh tiêu học đăng theo học,
tại các cơ giữa giáo dục con lại,
được khu trở hai vì tảm gình đồng trên một em chế một ngày,
chức học sinh và nhà trường thống nhất,
mất tên ăn cao hơn,
sò vời một em chế một khu trở,
thì vần chính lịch sẽ thương của người học.
Đà bảo mất ăn tối tiêu là mốn với gình đồng trên một em chế một ngày,
thời gian hỗ trở từ năm học hai gình thục trở hai vì sấu,
tới hai gình thục trở hai vì bởi theo số ngẻ ăn thực tế,
cho không thể ra năm học,
không qua trên tháng trên một năm học,
một kinh vĩ hỗ trở từng gần xanh nhận nước,
thành phố sự kiến xo học sinh tiêu học năm học hai gình thục trở hai vì sấu,
tới hai gình thục trở hai vì bởi gần bệnh trăm 4 mií tảm gình,
số bán chú khoảng 6,5 miền,
từ lẽ tảm bệnh trăm 8,5 xo vũi,
hòa gình thục trở hai vì lăm,
hai gình thục trở hai vì sấu,
thì tổng dừng tỏng đần sách nè xuất hơn bán gình xấu trong tiêu,
về khu trở bán bán chú thột sinh tiêu học,
tất cả được thành phố hành đổi thực hiện từ nếu học hai gình thục trở hai vì lăm,
hai gình thục trở hai vì sấu,
với tổng tình phỹ trên hai gình năm trong tiêu đồng.
Vì bán chất tình phố đánh giá việc nước đam vào buân đây đủ,
hợp vẻ sinh và cơn đổi sinh dưỡng,
giống học sinh các đủ năng được học tập buổi trởi bà dành đuền trong càng ngày học.